say I'm gonna be your motivation when
you come home I'm being lingerie I'm
Gonna Keep it nice and fresh and waxed
for you your food someone's daughter oh
[ __ ] I don't ask for a lot okay I mean
okay okay hold on hold on so yeah I
gotta see you I got you right yeah
interesting yeah that's crazy
Chris Mr organic is a high value girl
right right I don't know I don't know
from your brother what do you look for
in a woman so you heard all these
answers right what do you look for I
mean yeah like of course most of them is
going to stand on they pretty they gonna
[ __ ] you and all that come home I don't
give a [ __ ] about none of that [ __ ] man
like we get that damn a dozen like a
[ __ ] got bread [ __ ] I'm sick since 2
30 I'm smooth I even without the money I
had everyone I ever wanted so like just
because you're gonna be at my home when
I come there cooking I don't need that
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying I never
needed it you know what I'm saying I
need a girl that's gonna understand
where I go through we're gonna keep the
[ __ ] on top of his toes it's
gonna push him and motivate him you know
I mean that's also going to come with
some ideas you know good answer give me
credit a girl that's going to keep you
motivated you think that's girl that's
gonna push him to be his best is what
he's saying girl's gonna keep him on his
toes keep him interested the guy doesn't
want everything easy not hold him down
yeah I know what you're saying and not
that that other woman would be holding
him down because it doesn't sound like
she'd be holding him down but she'd be
kind of like neutral she'd just be like
he said every other girl on the street
he could he's he's smooth he's got it
going on he's got money he can find any
girl to show up to on demand in lingerie
he doesn't need to marry it he wants to
marry something special indubitably yeah
I appreciate his perspective I mean
let's see what else he's got to say get
him on my grind you know what I mean
also add add to the to the table you
know I mean not just trying to grab some
food every time it's it's filled up you
know what I mean you got to bring
something to this table like [ __ ]
[ __ ] is over with after a certain time
like we could I could [ __ ] any [ __ ] I
ever wanted in my life I always have
that's not appealing to me no more you
know I mean once you get money and once
you was already having that you got to
bring more your energy got to be right
this girl ain't got to be right that
body don't mean nothing well she said
he's so right and in the long run you
know the the 25 year old gorgeous
everything the fluffy shiny hair the
perfect skin the tight everything the
cellulite free ass all that goes away at
some point so if you don't have any real
substance to bring to a relationship
what what are you gonna bring what is
she gonna bring when she's 60 she's
still going to be standing there in a in
a in a lace Teddy oh yeah and she might
look still look good for 60 but still
it's like the Leonardo DiCaprio rule you
know how he like like all of his
girlfriends he stops dating them at like
the age of 30. yeah that's who knows
what that is who knows what it is but I
guess that goes back to only marrying
based off of that or being with a girl
based off of that and then once they get
to a certain age and then there's
younger better looking women right how
deep are these relationships I can't
judge Leo I don't know but this girl is
sitting here and she was just so pleased
with herself when she said that like she
was bringing the most absolutely
wonderful thing that any man could ever
want to the table I shave and if that
was the best thing in the world she'd
already be snatched up she wouldn't be
sitting dressed like a hoe in a podcast
yeah you know so that's that's that and
I actually feel sorry for her though
because he's like [ __ ] that ain't
nothing and you know her big prize that
she just created in her mind has just
been [ __ ] on and I feel a little sorry
for her but I'm hoping she's learning
from it it's funny after a while you
know what I'm saying a [ __ ] will [ __ ]
anything man
so like you could be the baddest [ __ ]
in the world that's fine [ __ ] have you
and I'm gonna [ __ ] a [ __ ] a two one of
three [ __ ] would do that yeah happens
all the time you know what I'm saying
Jay-Z yeah Beyonce he still for some
other [ __ ] how could you beat that
because he would just want some new
[ __ ] on his car so that ain't nothing
man
what you bringing to Help Me Grow that
was going to help us grow that what
counts yeah preach brother but a bad
[ __ ] brings inspiration
no real [ __ ] that already had that if
you got a fat lame rich [ __ ] that need
all I just want a bad [ __ ] that [ __ ]
he's a square he's a nobody yeah but a
[ __ ] that been sufficient his whole
life and got every girl he wanted what
is a bad [ __ ] doing for me that's
nothing
we always had that what you bringing
more than just being it's a oh it's a
million bad what is the definition uh of
a bad place of a bad [ __ ] because I
don't really know does that mean is it
what she said like gorgeous and hot and
yes and koi it's just based off of looks
like damn she's bad she's good looking
she's not like when I like I always
thought that bad meant like Kick-Ass
like yeah just a bad [ __ ] I'm
just gonna you know no she don't mess
with her oh there's so many bad [ __ ]
here oh that just means like hot fine
bro there's no bad [ __ ] here where
are the bad [ __ ] at once the bad
[ __ ] get there I've been so sad for
her that that's where she places all her
worth because when that starts to go or
if God forbid something bad happens to
her looks like she gets a facial
paralysis or Burns or you know gets into
some kind of an accident like she's
gonna lose her [ __ ] mind she's not
gonna have anything else she's gonna
have to then start building up her
character and her intellect good thing
she shaves but good thing her thing is
I'll waxed and fresh I hate this [ __ ]
that's the cheapest and most easiest
thing is a [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] like I
said you go to Brazil right now it's
gonna be a 10 000 bad [ __ ] you ever
seen in your life you get them [ __ ]
one dollar in a coffee and that [ __ ]
gonna lick your feet man that ain't work
it's worthless to a real [ __ ] man right
you're gonna be a fat slow brain regular
ass [ __ ] that finally got some money to
be imposed and I got no I got a bad
[ __ ] like come on man like that's a
different type of breed of human that
they rocks off to that you know what I'm
saying and I get it y'all get your money
now go get all them [ __ ] but a [ __ ]
like me that [ __ ] is like there's
nothing you know what I mean
[Music]
that is somebody that you want to talk
to over a bad [ __ ] that will inspire
you
yourself a bad business no yeah I do
actually so you above basically what you
don't work you have no attributes to the
table here
I'm I Inspire my men wow you don't got
no job you got what's your education
but you have to no but you have to
realize that when men make it to a
certain level right they're not checking
for a woman's education they're not when
you're when you're making millions of
dollars you don't care about a woman's
education yes you do talk to Olivia rich
man
I got a state of Malibu okay yes I've
told you this I've told you what he's
saying that it does matter you want an
educated woman you want a woman that
when you're sitting at the kitchen table
or in bed at night you can have a real
conversation about what the things that
are going on in your mind woman that's
going to help you solve your problems
like he said give you constructive
criticism push you to be better
constantly being better herself and
that'll inspire you if you're with
somebody that's like that but this girl
is you know so so we've had that
conversation about a woman you just they
just need to look good like that's
that's real boring this guy is so right
who is this guy Mr organic so what's
like what's their point then when they
because they also talk about like fresh
and fit on how you just need um like a
woman does just eat her looks and guys
don't look at that and guys don't care
about like what sports you play or
whatever the [ __ ] you do for like maybe
it's just like the in like the initial
attraction like At first like we could
care less about education and stuff and
then it's like if we're really serious
about you that matters or like where
does that come into play or like because
these girl like if you're beautiful like
you still don't need those other
attributes you know what I mean like to
become high value yes but if you're hot
you're already valuable in a sense like
you can still go to the get on the
tables and stuff like I know that's not
like True Value but you see what I'm
saying it's temporary short-lived value
that like all right you're gonna it's
gonna open the door I'm gonna get to the
table and get my free drink out of the
bottle because it's so much a girl alone
being hot is like a guy having like
money some clout a good good you know
you're like right okay good good status
like as a guy you already have to be up
here just to get on equal with the hot
girl right but to stay in a to stay and
keep someone's attention that's what
that's really because you're just hot
and that's it then you could you could
just be replaced easily yeah if you're
just rich and you can't make me laugh
and you're not smart smart to have like
the conversations I want to have and
you're not interesting and I'm
embarrassed to bring you around my
friends and family because you're a
[ __ ] dud it's it's a non-starter so
the that money and that beauty will only
get you so far it'll get you to the
table but it's not going to keep
everyone else sitting at the table with
you this girl maybe she's got something
interesting to say but she has only said
superficial things I Inspire my man how
and he's asking her how and she she's
got nothing to say if she was that
inspiring to men she'd have a man
that's educated
[Music]
[Applause]
what does that even mean a deed to
indeed means you uh when you own a piece
of property and you've paid it off you
give them the deed so like when you put
a mortgage on a house the bank owns the
deed on the house and when you pay it
off the bank transfers the deed to you
to show that you are the rightful owner
it could happen with a car you know
anything that requires some sort of you
know government registration
[ __ ] with loser fat old [ __ ] got
money negative but when you're seriously
when you reach a certain level you don't
care if that girl works as a bottle girl
you don't care if this girl has a dog
not for love and relationship and
building a family together her she's
wrong she's wrong you know yeah it's
funny because she'll take her out on a
date she'll she probably gets asked out
on an easy 10 dates or more a night in a
club you know that would be a slow night
she's getting a lot of attention maybe
it is with beauty and like that stuff
it's just the initial attraction and
then to keep the guy it's like I guess
it's the same thing as a guy like you
get you get some clout you get money you
do all that [ __ ] it really is just like
the initial step you get a nice car it's
just like that first step to meeting the
person and then you have to be
constantly attractive with like your
personality and stuff and it's the same
thing with women so I think I think
that's like I said it opens the door it
gets you to the table but a girl being
like Oh I'm a lawyer and it's like she's
not hot and it just like doesn't matter
to a guy you know what I mean right
right but that lawyer you are probably
more likely to sit and have a good
conversation with her and start to
develop it I don't even think
necessarily at least start at least have
a good conversation with her and if she
has a good personality you're going to
want to see her again even if it's as a
friend where this dummy once you've once
you've done your your magic with her and
you've had a good time maybe a few times
as soon as the next piece of eye candy
comes along you're gonna you're gonna
forget about her because that one is
more the same but maybe a slightly
different flavor that one was banana
though so it's pineapple and you're just
gonna keep going through it's like
retail therapy with these broads where
you find something of substance it's
like you know to use the retail therapy
analogy it's like buying a Burberry coat
that you're going to have the rest of
your life when you spent five thousand
dollars on it but it's not something
that the average person is just gonna
toss away after a season but they may go
to the to Target and buy a t-shirt that
they're gonna throw away next year does
that make sense yeah no I I totally get
where you're she's not a Burberry coach
she thinks she is but she's not she's a
Target t-shirt she's a Target t-shirt it
ain't about just one of something the
target t-shirt looks good at first and
it wears out it does not wash well it
doesn't wash well yeah it's big
how does this girl keep her I
was listening
you know fed and housed wait say that
again how does that I want to know how
that girl she says she she doesn't want
to work but how does she keep herself in
is she is she an online personality
where she makes money online because
that's worked probably an only fans girl
who knows but that's work it's not no it
is it is it is an interesting work and
it isn't it isn't the girl you want to
bring home to your mother oh honey so
what do you do for work show my titties
on the internet but only for subscribers
so it's fine yeah it's work though we
know how much work goes into this yeah
well the funny thing with the only fans
girls is like all they're doing is
taking the pictures and then like that's
that's all they're doing they're being
told what to take and then the rest is
being done by a dude behind the scenes
not all of them the bigger ones and a
lot of them but not all of them I mean
all the successful ones yeah how about
that teacher who was doing it and she
did you hear about her no she got she
was she was doing it she got caught yeah
so so students found out one of the
parents was you know founder online on
only fans and then the word got out and
she got put on suspend you know paid
leave while they did an investigation
because all the kids were talking about
it and it turned into a thing and the
parents are like get rid of her which I
I think is gross initially I was like
leave her alone she's got a side gig it
doesn't bother anybody sorry that your
husband was you know hanging out in the
closet with her but with a picture of
her on the phone but it is what it is
but then it turns out that she did some
filming in the school bro in a classroom
because she was the Naughty Teacher on
only fans oh my God and so not only did
she lose her job only fans kicked her
out because only fans has has policies
about you can't do that in public places
and in elementary school classroom yeah
it doesn't now you're just now you're
just a Scooby skank so she lost her job
and her and her only fans job and who I
don't know what she's up to now you
think that she should have kept her job
like even if she wasn't doing it in the
classroom you think she should have kept
her job initially if it had nothing to
do with anybody and it was just people
that were mad that she was doing that
when the kids didn't know it was adults
that let the kids know or leaked it to
the kids find out that [ __ ] though like
they just like that happens like in
middle school because parents are
talking about it in front of kids yeah
but I don't think as a teacher you
should you should be doing that I think
you're supposed to be an example for
kids I don't think you should be doing
[ __ ] only fans even though I know
teachers aren't good examples but I
don't I don't want teachers if I'm
running a school and the teacher is
doing only fans I'm saying you're either
stopping that [ __ ] or you're fired Mark
could be like it doesn't hurt anybody if
you're the principal what are you gonna
do listen I'm not advocating for only
fans but the fact of the matter is our
teachers don't get paid a lot of money
they all have I when I was a young uh
when I was in college and I was a
waitress I worked with teachers people
who were already out of college they
were young teachers and they they were
worked three four nights a week after
teaching every day and they worked all
summer long in the restaurant because
they just simply couldn't make enough
money as a teacher so they need a
secondary income until we get to a place
where we should pay them properly so
only fans is an easy secondary income
that she had geographically she had it
set so that people couldn't find her
within you know 50 miles or whatever I
don't made that number up but of her
house so what the hell is she really
doing wrong it's legal it's it's
socially weird you know not socially
acceptable necessarily but it's nobody's
business she wasn't breaking the law but
then when she when she broke the law and
did naughty things in a little kid's
classroom she got everything she
deserved so thank you for watching
tonight uh if you guys want to learn
more about how to blow up your channels
on social media and grow your businesses
on social media join Sonny's Discord
where's the link in the description in
the description join Sonny's Discord
start having the conversation and if you
think it's worth it join his gsda get
shits on Academy which I think it is
worth it but he's getting the Discord
because there's so much good for you
information and you should be exploring
see if this is for you and thanks for
watching okay bye guys if you got a
skanky teacher on only fans I say leave
her alone Sonny says Tanger in the Town
Square
[Music]
[Music]